flowers can make the holidays even
happier so Tammy Porto bartolomeo owner
of the wild Nomad Flower company is here
to show us a very special way to Deck
the Halls welcome Tammy hi nice to meet
you thank you for having me first I just
have to say I love your Vibe I love this
entire aesthetic it's so it's giving
like hippie vintage Vibes yes that is
that was the goal that was the goal so
cute now what was the inspiration behind
this adorable business well you know I
think I've always been really creative
throughout my entire life so when I had
my son I decided it was time to do
something absolutely now what is this
something what can people do with the
wild Nomad so flowers I think you know
for me it's always about just you know
putting the creativity out there and
letting people experience so for me it
was about curating experiences and so
with the truck people can make flowers
they can make arrangements they can make
bouquets or whatever it is that they
want to do they just come up to the
truck and well with that said let's head
to the back of the the Volkswagen the
Vintage Volkswagen Chuck I have to make
sure you know what this is it is very
cool
and this is where you actually make the
flower arrangements yes yeah so
basically we can pick flowers from the
truck and then you can put them together
either in a bouquet so this is a sample
bouquet that we would do or you can make
a flower arrangement so for that you
just can use any phase that you have you
have the supplies over here look at this
yeah so you can use the unique Clippers
you need some tape some chicken wire any
opinions that you have at home the whole
goal really is to encourage people to
come out and really just you know pick
flowers that speak to them and make
arrangements so whether it's the
holidays or if it's you know just your
your hosting a dinner or you're going to
a dinner party and you want to bring a
bouquet that's basically
um you know the gist of it yeah one of
your your your mottos is bringing the
community together one stem at a time I
love that but let's get specific about
the holiday season what florals or what
trends are you seeing out there for
people who want to make arrangements so
I think it's always about the seasonal
what's in season for us for me I know if
I'm doing a fall holiday I want to stick
with the fall tones so I go with like
the ambers the maples
um you know an amaranth or I'll always
mix in some kind of roses uh ranunculos
are always good and I think you know you
just kind of transition into those
holiday those holiday
um
it's kind of what is out at that
specific time so with winter you know I
might do something more white or you
know focus on the Foliage for the
greenery just the different types of
foliage that you have okay and how do
you get you know how can we get in touch
with you how can we get you rolling up
to our birthday parties or holiday
parties so you can always reach out to
me I have Instagram it's at Wild Nomad
flower Co I have a website you can reach
out you know DM me whatever okay well I
just have to tell you you guys want to
hang out and make floral arrangements
with Tammy okay this is so cool thank
you so much thank you
all right Ted we will send it to you for
the weather because it is a little cool